ام
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
سفينه نرويجيه سويديه مشتركه ابحرت من
السويد عصر الاحد باتجاه الجنوب للانضمام
الى اصول دولي يعتزم كسر الحصار
الاسرائيلي المفروض على قطاع غزه منذ عده
سنوات نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
محورين
كيف نفهم غياب المبادرات العربيه الراميه
الى كسر حصار غزه بموازاه المحاولات
الاوروبيه المتكرره لكسر هذا الحصار
من الخطوات المطلوبه لتفعيل الدور العربي
رسميا وشعبيا يتجاوز الحصار الاسرائيلي
على القطاع
[موسيقى]
حسب دراسه اعدها مركز فلسطيني لحقوق
الانسان فان اكثر من ثمانين في المائه من
سكان القطاع باتوا يعتمدون على المساعدات
الدوليه نتيجه للانهيار الكبير في مختلف
جوانب الحياه جراء الحصار المضروب على غزه
منذ صيف عام الفين وسبعه لكن ورغم الوضع
الكارثي الذي خلفه الحصار على سكان القطاع
فان اللافت ان مبادره عربيه ذات شان لم
تنطلق لمحاوله كسر هذا الحصار على الرغم
من ان شواطئ الجنوب الاوروبي شهدت العديد
من المحاولات لكسر حصار غزه
تنسى غزه تماما يتذكرها الاوروبيون والى
شواطئها هذه تبحر من السويد سفينه
النرويجيه السويديه لكسر الحصار على غزه
هناك تقلص مساحه الصيد امام الغزيين ويحكم
الحصار على رزقهم من البحر وفي البر يبدو
الدمار ذلك الذي خلفته اخر حروب اسرائيل
على القطاع الشامله البيوت المدمره عمر ت
ولا من تشرد عاده الى ما تبقى من بيوت هذا
ومره شتاء وجاء صيف اخر ومازال اكثر من
مائه الف غزه او يزيد في مساكن مؤقته اقرب
الى بيوت الصفيح بل اسوا حالا عقد من
ايديهم مؤتمر لاعاده الاعمار في اكتوبر من
العام الماضي بذلت وعود و تعهدات بما يزيد
على خمسه مليارات دولار لاعاده الفلسطيني
في غزه الى الحياه اليوميه كباقي البشر
لكن شيئا حقيقيا يعتد به لم يصل وليست
اسرائيل هي السبب دوما تمت عرب ايضا
يجتمعون على عجل من اجل اخر ازماتهم في
اليمن وعلى عجل اجتمع رؤساء اركان هم
وقاده جيوشهم للبحث في تشكيل قوه عربيه
مشتركه لكنهم لا يجتمعون الا بشق الانفس و
متاخرين دائما اذا تعلق الامر
بالفلسطينيين وهؤلاء اصحاب ما توصف في
ادبيات السلطات العربيه ومعارضيها على
السواء بالقضيه المركزيه الى العرب بل ان
الدوله نفسها التي تحتضن اجتماعات
المسؤولين العرب حول الشان الفلسطيني هي
الاكثر تشددا في فرض الحصار على الغزو وهم
جيرانها و عمقها الاستراتيجي كما تقول بين
الفينه والاخرى منذ مطلع هذا العام مثلا
احكمت القاهره اغلاقها معبر رفح فلم تفتح
حسب احصاءات فلسطينيه اكثر من خمسه ايام
فقط ما اعتبر الوضع الاسوء في تاريخ حركه
العبور بين قطاع غزه والشقيقه الكبرى منذ
زمان اما الاسباب شائكه بعضها ذي صله بما
يمكن وصفها بالنسيه الجريحه التي تضخمت في
عهد السيسي فاصبحت انتقاما اكثر منها
السياسه اضافه الى تحول غزه برمتها طوعا
او كرها الى جزء من صراع محاور يسعى بعضها
الى تصفيه تيارات الاسلام السياسي في
المنطقه كلها باعتبارها الشر نفسه ولا باس
لدى هؤلاء لو تم الامر بالتواطؤ مع
اسرائيل ان لم يكن بالشراكه مع ها
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من غزه
السيد رامي عبده رئيس المركز الاورومتوسطي
لحقوق الانسان ومن القاهره عبر السكايب
الدكتور حسن نافعه استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه القاهره ومن عمان السيد الياسري
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكم جميعا
والسؤال السيد الدرامي عبدو رئيس المركز
الاورومتوسطي لحقوق الانسان السيد رامي لك
من يتحدث عن ان هذه القوافل التي تاتي ب
اه اه شعار كسر الحصار المفروض على قطاع
غزه انما هدفها الاستعراض الاعلامي واحراج
بعض الاطراف العربيه
المشاركه او التي تتهم بانها مشاركه في
الحصار على غزه ما قولكم
يعني انا اعتقد انه هذا الامر لا يجب ان
يفهم هكذا هناك مسؤوليه يعتقد الكثير من
النشطاء في الساحه الاوروبيه ملقاه على
عاتقهم لانه هناك مسؤوليه اخلاقيه
وقانونيه كما هي مسؤوليه موجوده على ال ال
ال العالم في العالم العربي او على
المسؤولين في العالم العربي هناك من
يستشعر انه من العار ومن المعيب الصمت على
هذا الحصار الذي يدخل اليوم خلال هذه
الايام عام التاسع لا هذه ال هذا الحراك
حراك يخرج من منطلق حرص ومن منطلق وعي ان
هناك ما يجب ان يتم فعله وهذا الامر اتى
اكله في مراحل عديده لعلنا نستذكر على
سبيل المثال في عام الفين وعشره عندما
تحرك اسطول الحريه وكانت المشاركه
المركزيه في كانت مشاركه اوروبيه اسرائيل
اضطرت انذاك الى التخفيف من الحصار
المفروض على قطاع غزه واستخدام عناوين
اخرى لعلك تذكر انها كانت تستخدم معادله
الجوع او كانت تستخدم قائمه المواد
الممنوعه ثم تحولت الى استخدام ال المواد
ال مسموحه اليوم نحن نتحدث عن واقع ماساوي
للغايه نحن نتحدث عن مواقع كئيب اليوم
الناس هنا في قطاع غزه لا تشعر انه الحاجه
بالدرجه الاولى للغذاء والدواء وانما هناك
ازمه كرامه انسانيه يبدو ان الاوروبي
يستشعر منذ مده طويله ان هناك ازمه كرامه
انسانيه وبالمناسبه الحديث عن حصار غزه لم
يكن وليد لحظه فوز حركه حماس في
الانتخابات ال ال التشريعيه التي جرت في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وانما كان استهداف غزه قبل ذلك لذلك تجد
الجهود الاوروبي على سبيل المثال حتى على
المستوى الرسمي يقبل الحديث عن مائه لعلك
تذكر على سبيل المثال ان ميناء غزه عام
تسعه وتسعين بتمويل اوروبي وحتى هذه
اللحظه الاموال لا زالت مرفوضه لعلك تذكر
على سبيل المثال عام الفين وثلاثه تقدمت
النرويج بمقترح للجزيره مائيه عام الفين
وثلاثه وافقت عليه كل الاطراف بما فيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والرئيس الراحل ياسر
عرفات
و عارضوا طرف عربي لانه لا يريد ان يخسر
التحكم في بوابه قطاع غزه اذن الجهد
الاوروبي في هذا الاطار حتى
المصريه نرى انه المفوضين انا لا اريد ان
اتحدث عن اطراف يوجد طرف يدرك الجميع من
الذي هو معني بشكل اساسي في حصار غزه
الاطراف العربيه بشكل عام حتى في لحظات
معينه تتساوق مع استراتيجيه الاحتلال في
لوم الضحيه وحتى وضع شروط تعجيزيه على
الارض
من القاهره الدكتور حسن نفهم هذا الوهم
الذي اصاب الجسد العربي رسميا وشعبيا
ليس هناك مبادره واحده ذات قيمه او ذات
شان انطلقت من طرف عربي لكسر هذا الحصار
الذي يوصف في كثير من الادبيات العربيه
ايضا الرسميه والشعبيه
بكل الاشكال الملاحظه الثانيه ان
المبادرات
هي مبادره
اوروبا الرسميه ان توافق على الاقل او حتى
السياسه الاسرائيليه التي
المراقبين الاوروبيين
المهم بالنسبه للعالم العربي يعني كنا حتى
فتره قريبه كنا نلاحظ ان هناك فجوه بين
الموقف الرسمي والشعبي الموقف الرسمي كان
موقف مساعده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويخشى من
مواجهه اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن
شهر ما زال حيا يعني رافضه لهذا الحصار
ويحاول بالتعاون مع بعض المبادرات المجتمع
المدني الاوروبي وغيرها المساء في محاولات
رفع الحصار الان كل الشعوب العربيه تبدو
يعني منشغله بقضاياها الداخليه هناك ما
يشبه الحروب
هناك حروب اهليه فعليا وهناك مجاعات وهناك
توارث السنيه داخل اكثر من مائتين في
العالم العربي وبالتالي تراجعت القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولم يعد للحصار الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه نفس الاهميه او ليس
هناك نفس ال الوضع وبالطريقه نفسها
بالطريق اسباب كثيره وهي يعني تعم كل
الدول العربيه وليس يعني
الزعتر هل الفلسطينيون يساعدون انفسهم هل
يساعدون من يريدون ان يقدموا لهم يد العون
هل الفلسطينيون يتحدثون بصوت واحد هل لهم
حكومه واحده تمثلهم او كيان واحد يمثلهم
بحق هل هناك مصالحه فلسطينيه ناجعه حتى
اللحظه الراهنه حتى يستطيع الاخرون ان
يمدوا لهم يد العون
يعني هذا هذا الجزء من السياق هو الذي
يفسر الى حد كبير ما يجري لقطاع غزه ليس
هناك يعني حاله من الاستمتاع ب حصار
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
منظومه اجتماعيه موجوده في هذا المكان من
العالم لكن القضيه السياسيه بامتياز قطاع
غزه جزء من السياق الفلسطيني وال سياق
الفلسطيني مستهدف بمنظومه من التركيع يراد
تركيع الشعب الفلسطيني قطاع غزه تعرض
ثلاثه حروب خلال السنوات الاخيره من اجل
تركيبه لان هناك مقاومه ولان هناك سلاح
ولا ولا ان هناك خطاب يرفض التسويات
الهزيله للقضيه الفلسطينيه يراد ان قطاع
غزه ان ينضم الى منظومه التفاوض ورفض
المقاومه والتعاون الامني في الضفه
الغربيه التي يمثلها محمود عباس ما يجري
في السياق الفلسطيني وانا مصطلح المصالحه
الذي يتم ترويجه هو محاوله لترك يع قطاع
غزه محمود عباس لم يكن يعني غامضا في هذا
السياق تحدث عن انه يريد السلطه بالكامل
في قطاع غزه لانه يريد ان يضمها الى الضفه
الغربيه ويريد بعد ذلك ان يتحدث عن السلاح
الشرعي الواحد السلاح هو عنوان الاستهداف
لقطاع غزه والمقاومه هي عنوان الاستهداف
لقطاع غزه يشارك محمود عباس في منظومه
التامر والحصار على الشعب الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه حتى وهو يتباكى على الحصار وعلى
الجوع وعلى عدم الاعمار وهو يتواءم مع
النظام السياسي المصري الذي لم يحدث في
التاريخ منذ في تاريخ القضيه الفلسطينيه
ان حصل الكيان الصهيوني على نظام في
القاهره اكثر حميميه في التعامل مع الكيان
الصهيوني مما هو الان في في القاهره الان
هذا يحدث لانه يعتبر ان صراعه مع حركه
حماس وجزء من صراعه مع الاخوان المسلمين
في الداخل لانه يرد الجميل نتنياهو الذي
عمل مقاوله للانقلاب عندما وقع لان هناك
منظومه عربيه ايضا تدعم النظام ولها ثار
مع ما يسمى الاسلامي السياسي الذي تصنف
حماس كاحد مفردات وبالتالي هناك حاله من
الاستهداف لقطاع غزه ليس في سياقه
الانساني وانما في سياق التركيه كما هو
الحال في كل المنظومه الفلسطينيه في
تاريخها لو ان الفلسطينيين قبلوا
بالاحتلال بواقع الاحتلال لما كان هناك
حصار في اي لحظه من اللحظات كان بوسعهم ان
يوفر لهم الماء والدواء والتعليم وما الى
ذلك على ان يقبلوا ب بواقع الاحتلال ان
يعترفوا بواقع الاحتلال ان يركعوا لواقع
الاحتلال وهذا ما يرفض الفلسطينيين في
الصين منذ الانتداب ومن ثم الاحتلال
الصهيوني وحتى الان وقطاع غزه يرفض ان
تجري مقايضه اعاده الاعمار
فتح المعبر بنزع السلاح وبالتالي التنازل
عن عن عن كل الثوابت الفلسطينيه التي اجمع
عليها الفلسطينيون هناك مؤامره يشارك فيها
النظام المصري يتواطا معها
ان النظام او الجانب المصري اه ساعود الى
الدكتور حسن نافع واساله يعني هذا الكلام
هذه الانتقادات اللاذعه لها ما يسانده على
ارض الواقع من بيانات اه جاء مثلا في
دراسه اعدتها اه وزاره الداخليه في حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
تقول ان معبر رفح منذ بدايه العام الجاري
وحتى شهر ابريل لم يفتح الا خمسه ايام فقط
ما الذي يمكن ان يمثله مرور فلسطينيين عبر
معبر رفح الذي يشرف عليه الجانب المصري
وفق الشروط المصريه من خطر على امن مصر
انا لا اجد ان هناك اي خطر من اي نوع على
ان يمر كل من هو محتاج المرور عبر اه وقد
عبرت عن هذا مرارا وتكرارا في كل ال
المحافظه التي شاركت فيها وبالتالي انا
الي الاعلى
وكنت وطالب باستمرار باغلاق ال بفتح المعا
مرور
البضائع والتعامل مع السلطه القائمه في
قطاع غزه سواء كانت حماس او غير حماس
بمنطق الامر سلطه الامر الواقع التعامل مع
الاحتياجات الامنيه يعني تستطيع السلطات
الامنيه اعتقد على انها وسلم اه يعني من
خلال تطبيق الاجراءات المتعارف عليها بين
ال على الحدود بين مختلف ال اه الدول هذه
الموافقه الدكتور الدكتور حسن هذه موافقه
ضمنيه على ما جاء في كلام السيد ياسر
الزعاتره من ان ال النظام المصري يردوا
الجميل نتنياهو الذي عامل مق اولا
الانقلاب العسكري لا لا لا اطلاقا انا لا
ادخل في المزايدات يعني هناك اطراف
فلسطينيه وعربيه تستخدم القضايا للمزايده
على بعضها البعض انا لا هذه اللعبه اه
اطلاقا ولا ادخل فيها ان يعني ملتزم
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اه انسانيا وطنيا و
عربيا واسلاميا
وكلما لا تشارك يعني دخلت الى اه موضوع
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي
يعني نحن لا نناقش موقفك دكتور حسن الشخصي
لكن نناقش اه يعني السبب او ال ال السر
وراء هذا الموقف
انا اريد ان اسمع منك
ما يمكن ان يطرح هذا الطرح انا شخصيا لا
اجد اي خلافات كبيره او جوهريه بين الموقف
المصري منذ حسن المبارك وحتى هذه اللحظه
هي مساله نسبيه يعني يعني هو فرق اه ال
فروق في الدرجه وليس في النوع
[موسيقى]
هذا غير صحيح وهذا غير دقيق يعني ال ال ال
معبر رفح الذي يمثل رمز التعاون او عدم
التعاون مع الفلسطينيين كان مفتوحا في
السنه التي حكم فيها الرئيس المعزول محمد
مرسي تقريبا طول العام و بشروط اقل صرامه
كثيرا مما هي الحال كما كانت عليه ايام
مبارك والمجلس العسكرى ثم بعد ذلك في عصر
اه السياسي لم يعلن رسميا
رفع الحصار ولم يعلن رسميا فتح معبر رفح
على هذا ال ال النحو سنه اسرائيل يعني اه
حربا على قطاع غزه ايام الدكتور محمد مرسى
والدكتور محمد مرسي يتعامل مع حماس
باعتبارها امتداد لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وبالتالي كان موقفه مختلفا عن موقف الرئيس
حسني مبارك لكن من هذا المنظور الى
التنظيم والمنظور الايديولوجي والمنظور
العقائدي وليس من المنظور الوطني او ووفقا
لاعتبارات الامن ال ال الوطني ال المصري
او الامن القومي العربي وبالتالي القضيه
الفلسطينيه للاسف الشديد وهذا حتى اصحاب
القضيه الفلسطينيه لم يعودوا وحدنا حولها
البعض يرى ان عامه يعني ال الدوله الايدي
الدوله الفلسطينيه الاسلاميه هي الطريق
الوحيد نحو التحرير والبعض الاخر يرى غير
ذلك هناك من يرى ان المقاومه هي الحل
وهناك من يرى ان التسويه هي الحلول وكان
الشعب الفلسطيني موحدا لما يعني لا اكبر
الدول العربيه على ان تغير من
الى الى نقاش لهذا الطرح ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير
مشاهدينا الاعزاء بقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الصمت العربي اتجاه الحصار
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه في ضوء المبادرات
الاوروبيه المتكرره لكسر هذا الحصار اتوجه
في السؤال لضيفنا من غزه السيد رامي عبد
السيد رامي لو كان الفلسطينيون موحدين لما
تمكن هذا الحصار ان يصمد كل هذه المده هم
اه يعني يتحملون الجزء الاكبر من اللائمه
بسبب موقفهم المتشدد م هذا ما ردكم
شوف انا اسمح لي ان اتحدث بوضوح وبصراحه
صحيح ان ال الخطير في موضوع حصار غزه ان
هناك الكثير من الاطراف تحاول ان توظف
معاناه الناس ل ل نفعيه السياسيه لكن
الاخطر من ذلك ان هناك في حاله من ال
استعداء ل كل ما هو فلسطيني هناك خلق حاله
لبيئه عدائيه ضد كل ما هو فلسطيني ليس فقط
في اه بعض المناطق المحيطه وانما حتى في
العالم العربي بشكل عام وهذا امر شاهدنا
حتى اتجاه اللاجئ السوري هذا ترجم بتخاذل
للمجتمع المدني ال العربي حتى نتحدث انه
مثلا في اه اه فتره العدوان الاسرائيلي
الاخير كان هناك اكثر من الف واربعمائه
تظاهره في الساحه الاوروبيه في حين العالم
العربي لم تخرج تظاهرات بالعشرات هذا امر
بالتاكيد خطير لكن ما اود ان اقوله انه
موضوع حصار غزه اليوم هو موضوع لدى الجانب
العربي بشكل كبير لانه الموقف الاوروبي في
هذا الاتجاه سواء على مستوى المجتمع
المدني واسمح لي ان اختلف مع الدكتور نافع
ان ال المستوى الرسمي الاوروبي هو موقف
متقدم فيما يتعلق ب حصار غزه اذا نظرنا
الى المشهد اذا سمحت لي اليوم نتحدث عن
معبر رفح معبر رفح مغلق للمزاج المصري
ربما او الاوضاع الامنيه المصريه كما يقال
واه معبر بيت حانون مفتوح من اجل الابتزاز
الاسرائيلي للابتزاز بالمرضى الابتزاز
للتجار ابتزاز اصحاب الحاجات وهو مشهد
للاسف الشديد ماساوي لكن الاخطر ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدرك انه لا حل حقيقي
للازمه حصار غزه دون تفعيل وامر مائه لذلك
على سبيل المثال اجتمعنا في شهر ابريل عام
الفين وعشره داخل المفوضيه الاوروبيه وكان
هناك تفاهم كبير الموضوع معي في شهر يونيو
على
صدر قرار من البرلمان الاوروبي بدعم امام
اي اثناء العدوان الاسرائيلي الاخير على
سبيل المثال ووضعت المفوضيه الاوروبيه
تصور للمواد مره المائي و هم جادون في هذا
الاطار تحدثوا مع قبرص قبرص استعادت ان
تكون محطه وصول حتى الورقه الفرنسيه
الالمانيه التي قدمت في مؤتمر الاعمار في
القاهره تحدثت انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
اعمار حقيقي دون ان يكون هناك فتح ممر
مائي ال الاشكاليه الاكبر في هذا الاطار
انه هناك العديد من الاطراف تريد ان تبقي
غزه رهينه من اجل تحقيق هذه هذه الاطراف
يعني بعض هذه الاطراف التهم حتى حركه حماس
ذاتها يعني اه البعض اتهمها بانها مستفيد
رئيسي من وجود هذا الحصار عبر الانفاق
كانت هناك تجاره ضخمه هناك ايضا الضرائب
تحصل او اه يقال انها اتاوات تحصل من
المهربين هل هذا الكلام صحيح ام لا
انا لست في محطه الدفاع عن حركه حماس اذا
كان هناك حديث
الفلسطينيه
حركه حماس بالذات ولكن
مستفيده من الحصار
للاسف الشديد انا لا اعتقد ان هناك طرف
فلسطيني يستفيد انه يرى ابناء الشعب
ويجوعون يرى ابناء شعبه بهذه الحاله
المزريه هناك العشرات عشرات الالاف من
الاسر الفلسطينيه اليوم ناجحه في العراق
كنا نتحدث قبل العدوان على سبيل المثال عن
اطناشر الف شخص اه بدون ما
حوالي سبعين الف وحده سكنيه اليوم نتحدث
عن اكثر من مائه وعشرين الف نشهد ملامح
انهيار في القطاعات الخدميه على سبيل
المثال في فتره العدوان الاسرائيلي او
الهجوم الاسرائيلي الاخير كانت المستشفيات
تعمل اربعين بالمائه منطقه الانتاجيه قبل
العدوان كنا نتحدث عن مخصب حوالي سبعه
وعشرين في المائه بالمواد الطبيه والادوات
الاخباريه والمستلزمات الطبيه اليوم
الواقع ماساوي هل يوجد طرف فلسطيني او
الطرف الفلسطيني الذي يسيطر في غزه اه اه
سعيد بهذا المشهد لا اعتقد ذلك واعتقد ان
المهم الان لوم الضحيه الناس هنا ضحيه
للاسف الشديد لبعض الاطراف ربما يكون من
ان ينتفع سياسيا من هذا الحصار
ما المطلوب عربيا لتفعيل هذه القضيه
واه احداث نقله نوعيه في الموقف العربيه
رسميا وشعبيا من اجل كسر هذا الحصار
يعني ابتداءا انا لست معلوم ال الجماهير
العربيه والاسلاميه ربما هناك قضايا ملحه
هناك حاله من الحريق في المنطقه تجتاح
المنطقه هناك معاناه كثيره في الشارع
العربي والاسلامي وبالتالي هناك تعاطف
بالتاكيد والقضيه الفلسطينيه كانت وستبقى
هي القضيه المركزيه في وعي الجماهير
العربيه والاسلاميه لا خلاف على ذلك لكن
هذا النزيف والحريق الموجود في سوريا وفي
العراق وفي مناطق عديده وفي اليمن الان
بشكل اكثر الحاحا كل هذا يثير انتباه او
يعني يلفت الانتباه او يبعد ال اه صرف
الانظار عن عن المعاناه التي تجري في
الساحه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا في قطاع غزه
اما نشهد في الواقع ال هل هو عمليه اخضاع
سياسي عمليه ابتزاز سياسي من اجل اخضاع
قطاع غزه وضمها الى الضفه الغربيه هذه
العمليه تتواطئ فيها انظمه عربيه ويتوافق
مع ها تتوافق معها السلطه الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي وطبعا برعايه الكيان الصهيوني
والغرب بشكل عام وامريكا اضافه الى جزء من
المنظومه الغربيه ايضا يتواضعون في هذا
المسلسل من الحصار من اجل عمليه اخضاع
اخضاع الطرف الفلسطيني الموجود في قطاع
غزه من اجل نزع سلاحه وضم ال قطاع غزه الى
الضفه الغربيه ال المطلوب عربيا في واقع
الحال الان في ظل هذه الحاله من شبه
الاجماع او الاجماع على ال الوقوف الى
جانب ال ال ال ال ال ال ال الوقفه العربيه
في مواجهه التغول الايراني على المنطقه
مطلوب من الاطراف العربيه المحوريه عن
تبادر الى الضغط على النظام المصري او على
الاقل اقناع ال النظام المصري بالكف كف
اليد على ال قطاع غزه بفتح المعبر لانه ال
المشكله الاساسيه احد اهم المشاكل
الاساسيه التي يعاني منها قطاع غزه هو
مساله معبر رفح
الحريات الجغرافيه والسياسيه تقود دائما
كل القنوات التي تتحدث عن حصار غزه الى
الجانب المصري يعني قطاع غزه اذا كان
واقعا تحت الاحتلال قانونيا وهذا تقريبا
وتوصيف الامور
المتحده له فانه يحمل هذا الامر يحتم على
الجانب المصري ان يمد هذا القطاع بالمؤن
والغذاء والمواد الاساسيه اللازمه لاعاده
بل ان بعض الاجتهادات في القانون الدولي
تحتم على المصريين ماده المقاومه لهذا
الاحتلال بالسلاح هل تعتقد ان هذا في وارد
الحدوث مع التركيبه الحاليه للنظام المصري
انا يعني اريد
ال هو في وارد الحدود هل هو ممكن هل يمكن
ان يقبل مثل على هذه الخطوه وبين واجب انا
اظن ان هذا واجب او يتعين على النظام
المصري وانتاج الفرصه لان اشد النظام
المصري لانني لا اجد اي مبرر على الاطلاق
ان يبقى الفلسطينيون وخصوصا المرضى او
الطلاب الذين يريدون ان يلتحقوا
جامعاتهم ان يعاملوا هذه المعامله او
يظلوا اياما هكذا هذا غير هذا ليس مقبولا
على الاطلاق وبالتالي لن يستفيد النظام
المصري شيء سيخسر سمعته وسيخسر كل شيء لكن
هل نظام المساله على الاستعداد اعتقد ان
النظام المصري مقبل باشياء كثيره جدا في
الداخل هناك هجمات طاحنه هناك قضيه ان
هناك حاله اه خطيره جدا من الناحيه
الامنيه وهناك اعتقاد بصرف النظر عن ما
اذا كان يعني انا لا اعتقد شخصيا ان
النظام المصري يريد ان يعزل الفلسطينيين
لمجرد ان حركه حماس يعني يعني جزء من حركه
الاخوان المسلمين هو يستشعر ولابد ان
لديهم معلومات ان هناك استغلال اه اه يعني
ل ل لهذا في مسائل تمس في الامن هذا صحيح
ام لا ليس لديها المعلومات ولكن هناك
النظام المصري ان يقدم كل ما عنده لتخفيف
الحصار على مشاركه الدكتور حسن في
السياسيه في جامعه الخيره شكرا جزيلا لك
واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من غزه السيد رامي عبده
رئيس المركز الاورومتوسطي لحقوق الانسان
ومن عمان نشكر السيد ياسر الزراعه ال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم
ام
[موسيقى]
نعم
ام